يستبق اجتماع محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه فيحل في طهران مدير الوكاله
الرافاييل الروسي اختار ان يلتقي مسؤول
البرنامج النووي الايراني وهو محمل
بتساؤلات عن منشا الجزيئات اليورانيوم
ويبحث عن اجابات لما تبقى من ملفات عالقه
اثبتت ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم
المخصب لا يتجاوز نسبه 60% لهذا السبب ليس
هناك ما يستدعي التركيز على هذه النقاط
ويمكن القول انها سويت نوعا ما فيما يخص
المواقع الثلاثه وصلنا مع السيد بروسلي
لايطار عمل مشترك خلال زياره السابقه الى
فيينا وسنواصل العمل في الاطار نفسه
منسوب التفاؤل ولا يريد ان يكون متشائما
في التعاون مع ايران فهو يريد الابقاء على
صفحه التعاون مفتوحه بعيدا عن تجاذبات
السياسه كما يقول
يجب ان يكون لدينا محادثات جاده وعميقه مع
ايران فهي هدف زيارتي ما زال العمل جاريا
وستستمر اللقاءات مع رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايراني وبقيه المسؤولين وفي
النهايه سنكون قادرين على الحكم بشان
مستوى الرضا من هذه الزياره
حديث تقني بامتياز بين طهران والوكاله
بشان برنامج ايران النووي لم تعد تقيده
شروط الاتفاق النووي بعد انسحاب واشنطن
منه فازداد عدد اجهزه الطرد المركزي
وانواعها تقول الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان سقف انتاج اليورانيوم تنوع في
ايران منذ 2019 وتجاوز مخزنه ما هو منصوص
عليه في الاتفاق بعشره اضعاف ولا تزال
تبحث عن اجابات عن من شيء اثار لليورانيوم
في مواقع لم يعلن عنها للمفتشين في وقت
سابق قضايا ومستجدات يدخل عليها البرنامج
النووي الايراني فترتفع نبره التهديدات
القادمه من الخارج الاستهداف المنشات
النوويه فيلوح القاده العسكريون في ايران
بان اي تحرك سيقابل برد من دون شك
التهديدات الاسرائيليه عباره عن
بروباجاندا اعلاميه والمسؤولون العسكريون
الايرانيون انه اذا شنت اي حرب على ايران
فستكون حربا شامره تتجاوز الحدود
الايرانيه
اذا تحت وتيره التصعيد مع ايران على خلفيه
برنامجها النوم تسعى طهران الى تهدئه
الاجواء بفتح مسار تفاوضي مع وكاله الطاقه
الذريه وهناك من يرى في ذلك خطوه لوقف اي
تحرك اوروبي ضدها في اجتماع محافظ الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ياتي جروسي الى
طهران فهذا جزء من عمله للابقاء على
التواصل مع ايران كما يقول وهناك من يرى
انه لا يعني بالضروره حل الملفات العالقه
او خفض مستوى التوتر القائم مع الغرب على
خلفيه البرنامج النووي حتى لو تحدث كثيرون
عن ايجابيات التواصل بين ايران والوكاله
طهران